bonjour michel thomas merci de répondre
à nos questions direction arte france
récusation du juge suite à un recours de
députés et ex ministre
quid de la séparation des pouvoirs
législatif et judiciaire au liban la
séparation de pouvoirs sur le papier
dans la constitution
elle est prévue par la constitution
mais concrètement parlant et les
laiteries relatives au liban et ça ce
n'est pas nouveau en scène mais surtout
dans le cas d'une explosion du prof de
beyrouth
moi personnellement dès le départ je ne
m'attendais pas à ce que l'enquêté
aboutisse beaucoup de maisons réaliste
et objective parce que il faut
comprendre un peu ce qui s'est passé
quelles sont d origine explosion cadets
la cause de cette explosion
et qu'est-ce qu'il qu'est ce qui l'a
provoqué les milieux de l'opposition et
une grande partie de la contestation
disons les choses par leur nom il pointe
du doigt la seconde là qui contrôlait le
port et ses milieux de l'opposition ils
font assumer la responsabilité de cette
explosion
ça c'est un homme dénoncé au stade
actuel
c'est très simple pratiquement
impossible ça c'est 1 2 cette explosion
et les milieux de l'opposition aussi à
la contestation populaire relève ce
point a vraisemblablement été provoqué
par une intervention extérieure
une puissance donc une puissance
étrangère par le biais ou d'un drone
d'un missile
elle a occupé la hausse y est vous avez
délibérément se retrouver pour trouver
tout ça il ya des témoignages il y a des
il ya de nombreux témoignages qui
étaient présents deux personnes qui
étaient présentes sur les lieux qui
rapporte des faits bien précis et bien
concret et deuxièmement l'avis de
nombreux experts it is qu' il n'est pas
possible scientifiquement techniquement
une telle explosion d'une telle ampleur
étaient provoqués uniquement
st un sentier ou bien par la négligence
d'un peuple entier
on le dit la fim certaines sources
officielles donc tout ça c'est pour dire
qu' il fallait un peu s'attendre à ce
que l'enquêté n'aboutisse pas il a eu
intervention pression pour des knicks
vous dites inquiètes ne s'était certains
clans quête n'allait pas aboutir mais
mais maintenant coûte de l'enquète elle
est stoppée c'est fini ce qui va y avoir
un autre juge qui doit être nommé non il
ya des candidats donc l'enquète va
tacler effectivement effectivement le
conseil supérieur de la magistrature qui
est épais qui est présidée par un juge
dont l'intégrité et la probité sont le
contenu est par le pas même par les
milieux de l'opposition
ce conseil supérieur de la magistrature
seguini aujourd'hui même ou désigner un
nouveau juge d'instruction sur base de
suggestions et propositions du ministre
de la justice
ce juge n'a pas encore désigné et
devrait l'être d'ici 24 ou 48 heures
donc il faut attendre voir lequel les
pieds qui sera ce jusqu'à sorel son
identité et surtout qu'elle sera calé
son passé pour elle peut voir si
vraiment il pourra continuer le travail
accompli regrette du savoir sachant que
maintenant l'enquète dans le pack il
deux lots l'explosion a eu lieu à 6 -
pour le travail fait par la justice -
durant ces six mois donc on fait table
rase de ce travail le nouveau juge
d'instruction devra repartir de zéro et
c'est l'essence évidemment ça laisse la
porte ouverte à de nouvelles pressions
et de nouvelles interventions
justement est ce qu'on doit attendre des
interventions de la part de la
communauté internationale par rapport
notamment à l'aide internationale
mais alors de nombreuses voix s'élèvent
ici au liban --deux le départ pour
réclamer une enquête internationale
c'est parce que justement les milieux de
la contestation à fuir dès le départ ont
affirmé dès le départ qu'il y aura des
interventions politiques et des
pressions politiques tout le fait que de
nombreuses voix se sont élevées pour
réclamer une enquête internationale
mais le président de la république dès
le premier jour s'est opposé à cette à
cette démarche
donc concrètement pas grand
cette enquête internationale n'est pas à
l'ordre du jour certains pays comme la
france des états unis et la grande
bretagne ont de facto un peu participé à
l' enquête
lorsqu'ils se sont déployés au port de
beyrouth ils ont prélevé des
échantillons
ils ont effectué des analyses le liban a
demandé à la france des séquences les
images prises par satellite au moment de
l'explosion
donc le 4 août vers 18 heures donc la
france
on ne sait pas encore si réellement la
france a fourni ces images oui ou non
les informations étaient contradictoires
des images prises par satellite qui
permettrait de confirmer ou d'infirmer
cette intervention étrangère et de
confirmer donc les témoignages
recueillis par des personnes qui étaient
présentes dont des collègues ont décollé
à nous qu'ils étaient bâtiment d'une
arme
un exemple qui étiquette est située
juste qui est situé juste en face du
lieu de l'explosion et qui étaient ses
colères étaient présents dans nos
bureaux
ce fameux ce funeste 4 août à 18 heures
et qu'ils ont vu et entendu donc où des
drones au domicile des témoignages un
bien précis à ce sujet n'est sur le plan
de l'aide nationale le liban certains
pays hors pays de l'échantillon et
on attend de voir si ces rapports ont
été fournies ou non aux autorités
peut-être qu'ils ont été fournis mais de
juste savoir évidemment n'a pas divulgué
ces informations dernière question
rapidement et surtout ma on a vu une
manifestation à la nuit dernière après
c'est un non sens de la récusation du
juge
est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre ce soir ou
de les prochains jours à revoir des
manifestations de quelle ampleur est ce
qu'un nouveau soulèvement populaire est
possible à beyrouth après après cette
décision moment même où je vous parle il
ya un sit in qui est organisé devant le
palais de justice de baie vous ou
dénoncer d'abord cette mesure cette
récusation de deux juges sont moins une
délégation des parents banque cbc des
parents des victimes qui ont organisé ce
sit in une délégation de parents des
victimes a été reçu par le président du
conseil supérieur de la magistrature et
je le répète a toute la confiance de la
population en même temps la contestation
il leur a affirmé le nouveau juge
d'instruction poursuit poursuivra le
travail du juge sera avec sérieux et
courageux site
ce sont ces foires copain avec sérieux
et courage il en a pas dit plus que ça
évidemment mais n'a pas rien que le fait
qu'il ait reçu cette délégation
évidemment c'est un signe positif mais
il faut attendre voir la pop connaître
l'identité d'une autre instruction
elles sont passées et attendre voir si
il y aura de nouvelles pressions au
niveau du déroulement de l'enquêté
merci à michel thomas d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
co rédacteur en chef de l'orient le jour